foreign
comes from Mark in New Jersey last year
my wife and I made over 310
000 and this year we've made 250 000 uh
but we have still little to no savings
last night I decided to finally dig into
it when I came what I came up with after
doing this is that there was about a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
blown on who knows what this was a team
effort that I think we equally
contributed to every time I have a
conversation with my wife about money it
seems to end up being a fight she's a
very rational person so I'm sure it's
the way I'm approaching it how do I
bring it up without causing a huge flat
fight and allowing us to make a massive
change wow it's a good question mark
um yeah I love that he was like I'm
gonna investigate all right turns out we
blew 120 Grand on I have no clue I don't
know what yes man that's what happens
yeah I mean I think I would start the
conversation with you know
it I think in a humble way Mark I think
there's always something you know with
the humility side of like man I have I
have contributed to this which you've
already admitted and and I've messed
this up too like I have not
um done a great job communicating with
you I haven't done a great job uh
staying on top of our money and making
this a priority so I'm sorry like
there's just a level of humility there
and accountability yeah that I think is
a really beautiful way to approach it's
very disarming when you do that and you
kind of own your own stuff and you have
this level of like I didn't get it right
um and then obviously not letting her
you know just
yeah I mean like you know letting it
start to be a conversation though of
like okay so what do we want this to
look like now what do we as a team want
to look and have a vision for our
marriage and what are our goals what are
we what are we wanting to do because you
make great income like you're saying and
to be able to say man let's just take
this further and do it and do it on
purpose you know it's okay to still
spend money that's the one thing that
people think the Ramsay plan is like you
can't spend any money no you can once
you don't have debt and you have an
emergency fund you've taken care of what
you need to take care of you can't spend
money and enjoy so it's
um I think it's having that conversation
of like hey what does this look like for
us and let's still enjoy our lives well
let's do it on purpose with
intentionality amen Rachel I wish you
could just have that conversation you
know what Mark you know do it for you
but what this comes down to is not going
we have to get our budget today and
you're really screwing this up it starts
with that Vision where you go hey what
are our goals for the year because I
feel like we've been floating and we
have nothing to show for it we make
amazing money more than we ever thought
we would and here we are with nothing in
the bank and it's all just stuff and
food and shopping and I I feel like I've
done a terrible job leading Us in that
way and so I want to set some goals in
our life and once you set those goals
well now we have to make changes and
change some habits in order to actually
achieve those goals and one of those is
we got to get on a budget yeah and not
to you know constrict us but to give us
freedom so that when we do spend we do
it with confidence with no regret and
we're not derailing our goals that's
right now it's a different conversation
no regrets which we mentioned that in
our in smart money happy hour I
explained to Rachel I said it was an
internet meme it's beyond that of course
it's a scene from where The Millers and
Rachel was like okay what now it's a
great one it's a great clip go check
that out so thank you for the question
mark this is not going to be easy but
man it's going to be worth it and I
think if you approach it with that
humility and accountability it will go a
long long way